this just in my anime list is stupid my
anime list has appropriately a list of
what it qualifies as real anime ah well
let's get into how silly and wrong this
is first of all foreign animators even
entire foreign Animation Studios have
been a Cornerstone of anime production
for decades now to think that anime is
only created by Japanese professionals
was insane 20 years ago and it's insane
now second of all the majority of the
anime Market is literally overseas it's
literally why Dragon Ball doesn't have
much blood anymore they don't want to
bother having to censor it for the
bajillion International markets that
consume the entire show on mass like I
get it there is a decent reason to try
and distinguish between Batman the
Animated Series which was animated in
Japan but directed boarded composited
Etc in America and something like the
new Scott Pilgrim anime of which the
individual episode Direction storyboards
and animation are all produced in Japan
but for my money if you want to draw
that line the most sensible definition
is animated show where the primary
production takes place in Japan